violetta was geht ab max brod jetzt
willkommen zu einer runde stars zusammen
mit sp was geht was geht was gehe ich
bin schon damit wir machen euch die
schnelle schnelle und effiziente
schnelle machen heute die taktik hat
nennt sich schnell erfunden von
kurdischen militär und wir probieren die
heute mainz kairos aus funktioniert so
dass max als erster in die mitte gewesen
beide ändern hast du nicht mal irgendwie
sowas vollkommen rendering wie mit kurt
kurden gesagt hat jemand die content sg
hörst du hast du kunden
irgendwas war und ich habe keine kunden
ich habe mich nicht ich habe dir ganz
viele sachen bieten engagement junger
das ist echt ein traum kommt schon
welche jetzt könnte doch mal kommt er
werde jetzt eigentlich auch ankommen wer
traut sich noch nicht mal eben die
schwere des hasses nobody's oder sowas
nennt jetzt hier
dabei freuen
was vielleicht was ich schon mal neben
sich angekündigt habe sie übrigens finde
bei aber das geht relativ wahllos am
dreißigsten ist der ablauf der ersten
folge
es war eine turbulente erste folge so
viel sei gesagt ja ich habe super runter
zu werfen schneeball aber die distanz
ein bisschen zu groß hieß es ich habe
ihren schlitten werfen sondern lasst uns
mal schnell vor wollen wir machen dem
schnellen leute ist es glatt 10 28 weil
sich die auch noch ein bisschen gezogen
antippen und minecraft im 2
zudem seien made habe ich ausbilder
schmidt ein schneeball wir uns mal die
partie ist hier oben kommen statt von
oben
ob sie zocken oder auch nicht niemals
taten gehen ja auch nicht wie andere was
passiert mit dem japaner ist ja erstmal
aussortiert manchem so viel steht dabei
fiel den chip auch okay da ist einfach
erst mal 46 briggs bist du eigentlich
teil ist kurz weiß nicht ob ich dann mit
irgendwem bin irgendwann noch nie
hallo gast auf jetzt nur noch vier
spieler oder ware ist der typ davon ist
okay da kommen wir zu fuß sind
da kommt es zu fuß sind einfacher perle
sofort bewegungsmöglichkeiten und
fortbewegungsmittel
da können wir zu fuß sind oder ein
bisschen sport okay ich hab ihn dafür
dass der anreiz und gemüse kommt und
kein spiel zu gucken was noch ein gegner
keine spielchen spielt dessen der mitte
zieht euch durch
er macht jetzt 100% dieses da muss auch
fasst anne jakobi dasteht als bayer
der sei mit komm lass den wind den start
im westen machen können das kannst es
schaffen auf jeden fall der empore warte
da bisher bisher unsicher wird bisher
war unsicher seid ich unkonzentriert
wird genau da warten oder vorweist naja
erstmal schreiben bringt nichts
hey warum da kommt zusätzlich mit ghana
ist jetzt enorm
dieses macht das alles ab das schlau
gemacht hast
und so weit außen locken kann
als ob man es so freunde die minimoys
nächste runde aller zeiten aber es kommt
dafür heute noch ich hoffe ihr seid
nicht so oder ja in dieser funktion die
sauer sein
seid nicht sauer aber mein mann mein
ziel war jetzt erstmal wieder regelmäßig
was hochzuladen
wenn auch mal kürzer oder nun in pro
video oder so aber mir ging es selbst
voll auf die nerven dass ich so auf dem
vocoder deshalb ein mini video dafür was
relativ lustig eigentlich action und
action oder bist du nicht mal was gutes